if you're scared of AI I have bad news
you lost
[Music]
the quest
hey everybody it's Gary Bay nerdchuck
and this is like a weird impromptu like
we decided Midway doing through
something else show of the askgaryvee
show we were gonna do clips for social
media but then Sid made the executive
decision to turn this into an askgaryvee
episode which is super fun for me
because it is still we all know we
probably even just felt it right now we
need to keep figuring out how to put me
in Q a format because absolutely where
I'm best and so I hope you enjoy this
show here are some of the clips and
we'll see you next time what is the
biggest question that people have in
regards to what it takes to be a
successful entrepreneur
a big misconception is actually the two
extremes people either think that you
have to work super hard every minute and
like you gotta grind in 10 years and you
know or that it's like easy and lucky
and like people like stumbled into it
when in reality it's a massive
self-awareness game of the two which is
like of course talent but work ethic but
then one has to deploy it on
self-awareness on themselves so I think
the misconceptions sit on the two
extremes people got lucky that's why
they're a successful entrepreneur or
they [__] like worked every second
the reality is is what I get done in
eight hours is better than other people
get done in eight hours so it's not how
many hours it's what you do within those
hours those are the misconceptions
okay my question for you would be we all
know that you called The Tick Tock
explosion and massive growth years ago
and everything that's happening now you
predicted what is your next prediction
for other either the next app or the
next wave for social content creation
and entrepreneurs
so social media audience I'm gonna break
the fourth wall here Google it if you
don't know what that means the answer to
this question is how disappointed I am
with my team behind here by putting this
video in front of me they know that
there is no answer and it's fun to see
them in the background right now like
reacting to this like this is one of the
funniest videos I've ever made in my
career I am stunned that this video was
just put in front of me by my team
because they know the answer to this
which is I don't predict I don't have a
prediction I only react immediately to
what's actually happening I don't know
if lemon ate this or blue sky that or
this I don't know I know when the moment
is to fully go all in in the thing that
has now happened I'm not predicting out
here I'm moving quickly in the face of
reality quicker than most harder than
most that's the game all of you need to
play
hey Gary this is Adam my question for
you is what do you do when you feel like
you're plateauing in your business you
had success for a while and then you
start to Plateau how do you motivate
yourself to keep going and keep pushing
Adam a couple things one I hate the
Patriots and Celtics so you're sure
second but I love people from Boston
it's just a sports thing second there's
a lot of things to this the reality is
we have to be humble self-aware and and
honestly compassionate to ourselves when
you're hitting a plateau it's not about
motivation like you know I don't want to
be like a rah-rah guy for all of you out
there I don't mind it but those are like
little bursts that's not sustainable
sustainability comes from Clarity
Clarity is like why have I hit this
Plateau is this only as good as I am
nobody really wants to go there but like
Talent is part of the process uh back to
a lot of themes have I gone too hard for
too long and I just need a break like
maybe this is the summer for a lot of
you to just enjoy it because you've gone
too hard for four years and like you've
got to a place but you've plateaued and
maybe the plateau is happening from you
needing a little break think about
working out you know the people that
really know [__] they talk about rest
days like you can't pump buyer in seven
days a week and expect gains your body
needs rest well in the macro of building
a business or your project sometimes you
just need a rest day and that might just
be a rest summer maybe this is 2023 rest
summer for the people plateaued but this
goes back to nuances I want to make sure
real quick while I'm making this video
for the people that are crushing and
ascending this is not rest summer this
is continue to squeeze it's the living
[__] out of it because you haven't
plateaued summer right and so like where
people are not strong as being
contextual to find out why you've
plateaued there's a hundred reasons why
maybe competitors have come in and
created too much supply for the demand
three years ago you were the only one
doing oat milk ice cream and now all of
a sudden there's six more places in the
city that do oat milk ice cream and
maybe there was only so much demand for
oh so it might be external it might be
internal in general I can sense off the
video I really enjoyed that I posted a
couple of uh days ago or weeks ago
depending when team posted let's pop
that up team that long form video that I
really like
I think the thing that's always lost
when I talk is the nuances when I talk
about what I did in my 20s I talk about
that from a framework of self-awareness
of what worked for me it's nuances in
these split screens answering these
questions it's nuanced maybe you're
burnt out maybe you're only so talented
you should do something else maybe it's
the fact that there's more competition
and you need to wait for more demand to
come in maybe they'll never be more
demand and it's a fad and you should jet
the [__] out of the whole thing there's
a lot of reasons one may Plateau maybe
you haven't focused on culture and your
team is not working as hard for you
because now they figured out that you're
a dick not an innovator
could be a lot of things
there's like literally 900 answers to
that I can literally think of 45
different reasons that company would
plateau look at the one that I just used
at the end
maybe it's just your company's plateaued
because nobody around you believes in
you anymore because you've they've
they've snipped out your [__] you're
not a genius you're just a dick face
maybe you fell in love
Boston boy maybe you fell in love and
you're just like spending like you're
not spending every second on the
business and like you're you're
googly-eyed and that's beautiful and
maybe you know the honeymoon phase will
be over in a year and you can get back
to focusing on a business or maybe
you'll never focus on the business again
because you found a new balance and
that's [__] beautiful too like
there's just maybe maybe maybe maybe
maybe maybe maybe we have to be like in
general
like I have a feeling my 2024 content is
going to be about like the heaviness of
the nuances
Gary my question for you is for a lot of
athletes when that dream ends how do you
find a new passion to equivalent that
dream
all right first of all the amped AAA in
the background is the greatest thing
ever building V friends is going to be
amazing look I think this is something
I've been very passionate about I feel
so bad for people when a dream dies and
by the way there's a small group of
people in the world that it's around
Athletics what about the majority of
people who are straight A students or
good students and the dream ends the day
you're done with college you're like oh
[__] good grades in school means nothing
in real life like dreams die all the
time and so for athletes I think you got
to find another competitive Outlet I
think the thing that really hurts
athletes specifically is how much they
enjoyed the competitiveness of it and so
like that's why entrepreneurship and
business has been so big one of my
favorite things about the last 20 years
that entrepreneurship became a thing is
it became a place that athletes can go
when the dream dies or when the dream
dies out of retirement amount of
athletes now that don't have to be in
depression at 38 after having a great
career and what do they do with
themselves like they don't want to golf
they don't want to coach they don't want
to be a sports commentator a lot of them
are going into business honest I know a
lot of these athletes and it's been
beautiful to watch because I probably
went to business because I couldn't be
an athlete because they're close enough
you know what I mean and so I think for
all of us whether it's sports or how I'm
making this a bigger video which is
especially for all of you where you
realize the dream is over like school
doesn't guarantee you real life success
you got to reset and you got to find out
lots of what you liked if you loved
learning maybe you should go into
strategy and research and consumer
Behavior because you get to be curious
like so there's a lot of cool stuff like
that
we're gonna make this on our scary
interesting what do you say to people
who are scared of AI how can they
embrace it and use it for their business
by realizing they have no [__] choice
if you're scared of AI I have bad news
you lost AI is not going back into some
weird Genie
you know what what do I say I have no
interest in confusing people by the way
all these comments were like when I'm
putting out a stop they're like oh
you're getting supported by the AI like
there is no AI [__] Illuminati not
getting supported by anybody in AI this
is what you all said to me a decade ago
like Facebook you know every time every
time nobody's supporting me I want to be
historically correct you know who's
supporting me me I'm supporting my
[__] self by being right historically
and so it's not a very tough bet to
think AI is going to be a big part of
life it's the easiest bet I've ever made
it's a profound technology I'm a human
being I'm plenty scared like all of you
are like what does this mean in deep
fake videos and this guy I've got plenty
of anxieties I have anxieties about
everything just like any other human
being I just don't let them control me
like so many people
they sit equally to my optimism
the internet scared people cars scared
people tractors scared people everything
scares people social media scared
everyone you know like so there's pros
and cons to everything you can choose to
make it a con and be cynical or you can
choose to make it a pro and be
optimistic you decide but what do I say
I say nothing I really don't actually
care I don't talk I don't try to
convince any individual person on this I
put out content to be historically
correct but
I'm like what do I say nothing like you
don't want to use AI good people didn't
want to use the iPhone they eventually
did I knew people that told me they
wouldn't use the internet they did
people didn't want to use email they did
technology beats you every time all your
hot takes always lose to actual
technology ai's actual technology
these are from influencers in your
office good same for Max
hi Gary Max here I have a question for
you so I really love what you say about
patience right and I think that I'm
quite a patient person one thing that I
can't quite figure out for myself is
that my impatience comes from my desire
to impress my grandma and that's being
kind of my driver since I was a kid so
even though I am patient for myself yeah
I'm impatient because I want to see her
I want her to see me win and like do
well and know that I'm like not a
failure and I'm cool and I have impact
and all these things so I really can't
figure out what to do I love it what a
great great question
cool news legit grandmas and when I say
legit grandmas I mean grandmas who are
wonderful and have good intent not or
hurt themselves and are hurting a family
really don't give a [__] about these
accolades you're chasing they only want
you to be healthy and happy and you
chasing your dream is the happy not
getting the trophy for what you think
you need to accomplish she's already
proud of you bro she's already proud of
you you already accomplished what you're
trying to accomplish parents and
grandparents that and great grandparents
that have great intent are wise they've
lived and you know what they know the
trophy of winning the race doesn't
impress them as much as the training for
the race and the running of the race
that's real life and so good news
brother you've already impressed your
grandma you've already accomplished it
she already knows you're good promise
it's real too it's not only good it's
real like we all we don't even realize
it's actually selfish like we even
subconsciously or consciously know that
what I just said is right but we like
create a thing within ourselves no it's
not for me
I want my grandma to see I mate no you
don't and it's not in the bad way you
just don't realize that's what you're
doing
your grandma doesn't need to see your
Mercedes or a Rolex or your 10 million
dollar bank account she really does it
similar to what you said at the closing
keynote which was experience for kids
yours business success doesn't Define
how much they love you no child is
disappointed if their parents don't
build a big company
children are disappointed in their
parents when they don't get
unconditional love
[Applause]
if you're in here
unconditionally loving your parent but
your parent wasn't a massive business
success make some [__] noise
thank you
that was really cool right especially
when I asked everybody to like stand up
or not like
nobody here like loves their parents
because they made money not one [__]
person they only love parents if they
feel like their parents gave them good
intent
you don't have another one okay good you
were sitting on that one I'm ready this
one's Matt
what up G I'm in the office right now my
question for you is working with family
as someone that is a younger brother
what advice would you give me bringing
on my older brother to help me with my
content creating and media production
company any advice let's go my guy this
is a [__] tough one like for a
million different reasons family
Dynamics are real so you know even being
the older brother bringing in a younger
brother comes with a ton of baggage
you've got an extra one because the
natural way of things the older brother
is going to have all sorts of feelings
even if he's the most humble dude of all
time there's still some sort of like
animalistic like I'm the older brother
what the [__] kind of thing going on so
hey bro you have to and this is the
answer to everybody the only way family
businesses ever work is when everyone in
the equation has empathy and compassion
for the other people's feelings when the
kid comes in and actually has like
understand that your parents grinded
this for 30 years and came from nothing
and you can't just walk in because you
went to college and think you run [__]
and make sure you're empathetic to the
employees that have been there for 20
years and like you come in and now
you're their boss like they [__]
built that place on the flip side
parents in that scenario have to be like
yo the kids coming in with fire and
wants to like like prove themselves and
you got to give them a little room if
you're micromanaging and they'll never
and so for you personally hey you have
to have empathy for your brother it's
going to be a challenge B for everyone
listening you have to love your family
more than the money see all of you are
going to have ego and feelings all of
you and you need to understand that and
calibrate it D no matter how much you
fight try to end every night with like
that was [__] up but [__] it we're
family let's like be better tomorrow
right like that like you could have had
the biggest fight of all time but before
you both go to sleep this is good at
relationship advice but definitely in
family business I think it's even easier
than like personal relationships even if
it was like the worst day and you
literally like [__] you no [__] you at
work before you close your eyes that
night even if that fight happened at 4
pm and it's 11 30 p.m just like muster
up being the bigger person and texting
be like yo bro I know today wasn't great
but like we're fam over this like we
don't even need to have this business
we're fam like understanding that like
that's really real so like you know
being patient you know when you're the
leader and you're bringing in a family
member you got to teach them so there's
a lot there those are just some things
to keep an eye out for
[Music]
thank you
foreign